number one take an old sheet and cut it
into strips wrap it around the front of
your door tie it wrap it around the
front of your door until your whole door
is covered and then you can make some
fun googly eyes and stick them on the
front and then you've got a mummy for
your front door right how cute is that
another thing that you can do is you can
take old lampshades or you can thrift
lampshades take a little bit of black
construction paper cut out ghost mouth
and eyes and just tape those right onto
the lampshades put them on either side
of your front door with some battery
operated lights and you've got like a
fun little halloween situation going
number three would be trash bags so a
great thing you can do is take a pool
noodle bend it in a circle hot glue it
together and then just take trash bag
strips one trash bag cut it into strips
and then just tie it around that wreath
and it'll make this like big fluffy
black wreath and you can put that on
your front door so those are my three
top halloween tips